يزيد حاتم احمد العرقان اخذونا من البيت
اعتقونا ودونا على اسرائيل جوا تعذيب
واليوم افرجوا عنا طلعونا على دوار الكويت
نا خمس ايام موجودين من غير اكل ولا شرب
ولا شي بس نادر نفه صغيره بوق صغير وقبضه
صغيره هيك فين وب كله
تعذيب محمود نادر زنا انا كنت في بيت دار
سيده في وادي العرايس كنا قاعدين بامان
الله اللي احنا بنسمع صوت هذا تشرفه
اليهود مقاربه وبتجر رحنا استسلمنا جنا
بنت خالي خالي جازه فيها معها الرايه
البيضاء اجت بدها تطلع اول مره اليهود قنص
عليها طلقوا اج طلق جنب رجلها الله حماها
رجعوا لا هو ايش رجعت كمان مره طلعونا
فتشونا قالوا لنا هاتوا لنا جوالاتكم
نسقوا جوالاتنا وحطوهم فوق ال جوال وكمان
شنتنا اكلنا فيش فرجونا بين الاولاد
والنسوان الاولاد من ال 14 سنه وفوق
يعتبروا مع الشباب والاولاد من الاقل 14
بروحوا مع النسوان امي وخواتي ما بعرفش
انا
وينهم يا صحافه يا اخواننا اللي صار معنا
هذا كنا ماشيين كنا في الدار فاجت كانت
يهوب جرفه بالارض اللي ورانا ف فصارت
الدار ترج واجوا على الدار اللي جنبنا
واحتلوها فصاروا يطخطخ نار علينا يطخ على
القزاز فانزلنا سلمنا حالنا ق حطونا في
ارض لحالنا احنا الصغار وطلعوا وطلعوا
الكبار حطوهم على جنب وصاروا يمسكوا بصحون
القزاز سمعنا صوت القزازه بينكسر على على
الناس واه وص واش واليوم الثالث نفس
الشغله قلنا له بدنا ميه بقول في ميه قلت
له بس شويه ميه اعطاني نتف هالقد هقد
الميه طاحو من الساعه اعه الفجر حكوا هذا
ودونا على المستوطنه الثانيه نعرفش وين هي
وقعدوا جوا يسببوا علينا ويحكوا كلام وسخ
وشوا ميه علينا ويغرقو بالميه والدنيا تلج
واحنا وفي كانوا مش لابسين
حاجه حطونا في بركس كله رز على الارض قال
يرش الرز واحنا عشان ما نعرف ننام واحنا
معصبين علينا وهي ايدينا ه هدول ايدينا ها
هدول ايدينا اثر كلبشات كان مرابط
بلاستيك خمس ايام هدول واحنا مصبين عينينا
وايدينا كلهم من المرابط مربط ورا ظهورنا
ميه فش اكل فش حمام فشك حمام اعمل على
حالك ميه طاره بالخمس ايام جابوا لنا مره
واحده اكل عشان عشان ماكون كذابين جابوا
لنا لقمه هالقد قد لقمه العصفور هالقد هيك
خمس في الخمس ايام جابوها مره واحده بس في
الليل وصحوه من الليل وقالوا لنا كل جبنا
جبنا وحمص وصار ايه صار يقولنا ص طلعت
فاضيه وقد قد العصفور ما عملت اي حاجه
وه
دبحنا في ذب